Trascrizione: Paola B
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Buongiorno.
Io sono un entomologo.
Un entomologo è
una persona che studia gli insetti.
Quindi io, tutte le mattine,
mi alzo, vado in un laboratorio
e studio questi piccoli animali a sei zampe.
Probabilmente molti di voi penseranno
-- credo anche giustamente --
che la mia professione sia un po' bizzarra
ma sono altresì sicuro che
alcuni di voi penseranno
che sia una professione un po' inutile,
legata a quelle persone
che in una torre d'avorio,
studiano cose
avulse completamente dalla realtà,
dalla vita di tutti i giorni.
Ebbene vi vorrei dimostrare
in questa mia piccola presentazione
che non è affatto così,
che la mia professione
può dare invece un grande contributo
alla società
e alla quotidianità.
Vorrei così iniziare --
portandovi con la mente
in una bella giornata estiva,
magari una giornata di vacanza
che avete probabilmente passato
al mare o in montagna
e sicuramente avete visto
questa scenetta idilliaca
degli uccellini in questo caso le rondini
che volteggiano nell'aria -- magari
quella inondata dalla luce calda del tramonto
perché appunto questi uccelli
volano soprattutto al tramonto.
Se guardiamo questa scenetta
con gli occhi dell'esteta
parleremmo o comunque diremmo
parole tipo bellezza, gioia, poesia.
Se invece guardiamo la medesima scena
con gli occhi del naturalista
ebbene gli aggettivi saranno
completamente diversi.
E infatti per un naturalista
questa scena è una vera e propria
battuta di caccia
e particolarmente efficiente.
I guizzi veloci delle rondini
altro non sono che dei guizzi di caccia
con cui predano gli animali, gli insetti.
È una battuta di caccia, diciamo in miniatura.
Gli urli, gli striduli che emettono
sono dei veri e propri gridi di battaglia.
Ma se raffrontiamo ulteriormente la scena
e guardiamo questo volo di rondini
con gli occhi dell'ecologo
useremo altri aggettivi.
Infatti l'ecologo,
altro non vede che un passaggio di energia
da un'organismo all'altro
in un modo che possiamo addirittura definire democratico
Qual è l'energia che passa attraverso gli animali?
Possiamo approssimare e dire che l'unica energia
almeno sulla superficie della Terra,
è l'energia del Sole.
Quindi, l'energia che
io adesso sto utilizzando per parlarvi,
l'energia che voi state utilizzando per
- spero - ascoltarmi
è l'energia del Sole.
Siamo tutti macchine solari.
Ovviamente non giriamo
con dei pannelli fotovoltaici solari nella schiena.
Quindi noi ne beneficiamo secondariamente
-- del sole.
Ecco questo è il sole che arriva sulla terra
e che dona energia a tutti gli organismi.
È un'energia pazzesca, imponente,
incredibile.
Pensate che equivale a un'esplosione --
la medesima energia di un milione di ordigni
che -- dovrebbero scoppiare sulla Terra.
-- una potenza enorme.
La maggior parte di questa energia
si dissipa in forma di calore
e quindi abbiamo queste belle giornate
così tiepide, ancora autunnali.
Ma una parte di questa energia invece
viene inglobata
in speciali organismi.
Forse molti non lo sanno, ma tra di noi
vivono delle specie di alchimisti,
organismi che sono de veri e propri alchimisti.
E sono loro: sono le piante.
Pensate prendono l'energia del sole,
l'associano a dell'acqua e dei sali minerali
e diciamo così, li frullano al cloroplasto --
sto un po' semplificando -- e ottengono
dalla sostanza inorganica degli zuccheri,
zuccheri che poi entrano nei flussi di energia
e nutrono tutti gli organismi
e in particolare noi che invece non possiamo
sfruttare direttamente l'energia solare.
L'anello di congiunzione tra le piante e gli altri animali
sono gli erbivori.
Sono una categoria piuttosto ampia
di animali chiamati erbivori.
Bene, se pensate alla placida mucca
che bruca l'erba,
o se pensate a un cavallo che dopo una galoppata
così, si mette a mangiare,
si ferma e mangia l'erba.
state sbagliando.
I veri erbivori
cioè il vero anello di congiunzione
tra le piante e gli altri esseri, organismi
sono loro, sono gli insetti.
Gli insetti,
nonostante la loro piccola dimensione,
sono degli animali estremamente voraci.
E poi mentre un erbivoro,
della classe dei mammiferi,
si nutre di foglie, di fiori, di frutti o di semi.
Gli insetti sono un po'
come noi emiliani facciamo con il maiale
cioè non disperdono niente, utilizzano tutto.
Quindi mangiano le radici, le foglie, il legno,
il nettare, le corolle, le gemme,
insomma tutto, mangiano tutto.
E poi se guardassimo a questo mondo --
se arrivasse un extraterrestre
con solo delle cognizioni di statistica
approssimerebbe e potrebbe dire che
il mondo è abitato solo da insetti.
Infatti pensate che più del 70% delle specie
viventi su questa Terra sono insetti.
Per non parlare della massa, dei numeri,
dei milioni, dei miliardi di insetti
che vivono tra noi.
Non si vedono perché sono piccoli
ma hanno una biomassa imponente,
tant'è che un esperto in statistica
assumerebbe che
il nostro mondo è abitato solo da loro.
Quindi l'energia trattenuta,
l'energia solare trattenuta dalle piante
viene veicolata al resto del mondo
attraverso questi piccoli animaletti
che normalmente e ingiustamente
vengono considerati
come degli animali da schiacciare
o da non considerare.
Per questo motivo, gli insetti entrano
in tutti i cosiddetti flussi di energia.
Ebbene questa danza millenaria,
questo anello di congiunzione
è in crisi.
Pensate dall'inizio del '900
il tasso di estinzione è aumentato
di circa mille volte.
E il piede sull'acceleratore
lo abbiamo messo noi
distruggendo da una parte la biodiversità,
gli habitat,
e dall'altra inquinando il nostro pianeta.
Pensate che una pianta su cinque
rischia di scomparire per sempre.
Una delle principali colpevoli è l'agricoltura
che predilige solo alcune piante
mentre le altre le considera erbacce,
male erbe.
E quindi gli insetti e le api
stanno subendo
una diminuzione demografica
mai vista nella storia della natura.
Che fare?
Ci sono tante soluzioni ovviamente
e fortunamente.
La diapositiva che vedete è una di queste.
Prende il nome di hot spot di biodiversità.
Sono delle piccole aeree
che vengono coltivate
con una densità di biodiversità particolare,
a beneficio di un determinato insetto
rispetto a un altro.
Quello che vedete è la prima volta
che è stata utilizzata questa tecnica
e consiste nel costellare un determinato territorio
con tanti punti caldi di biodiversità.
Questa è una mappa della California --
sono stati creati questi microspot
per salvare una farfalla che si chiama
- si chiama per fortuna -
Mission Blue,
che era entrata verso la fine degli anni '70
nel libro nero delle specie in via di estinzione.
E grazie a questa tecnica invece
adesso se andate in California
e magari andate in spiaggia, potrete farlo
attorniati da queste farfalline bellissime, blu.
Tant'è che consiste in questo -- appunto --
costellare un territorio con questi micropunti
e questi punti verranno messi in rete dalla natura
e creano un grande ecosistema
secondo l'assioma di Odum,
un grande ecologo che dice:
"Tanti piccoli ecosistemi
fanno un grande ecosistema".
Questa è la farfallina, la Mission Blue
il primo insetto ad essere salvato
grazie a questa tecnica.
Ora invece dalla giornata estiva dell'inizio
vi vorrei portare in una grande città,
in questa colata di cemento
e vorrei farvela vedere
con gli occhi del naturalista e dell'ecologo.
Per il naturalista e per l'ecologo,
la città è un disastro ambientale,
è appunto una coperta grigia
che distrugge tutta la biodiversità,
distrugge intere aree di natura.
E distrugge vaste aree.
Pensate che dal 2007
la maggior parte della nostra specie, abitante della Terra,
vive in città e non più nelle campagne
come invece era uso fare.
E dall'inizio degli anni '90
la nostra penisola, la nostra bella Italia
è stata cementificata con un'area
pari a quella del Lazio,
quindi un'area vastissima.
Però se guardiamo la città
con gli occhi di un agronomo,
la scena sarebbe decisamente diversa.
L'agronomo vedrebbe tantissimi punti
potenzialmente coltivabili.
Tantissimi luoghi -- pensate la città
quanti davanzali, balconi, terrazze,
angoli verdi presenta.
Angoli appunto coltivabili con del verde.
E chissà quanti agricoltori,
in questo caso proprio in erba,
vedrebbe l'agronomo
tantissime persone che tra l'altro hanno anche
una sensibilità ecologica,
e che normalmente hanno
un livello culturale piuttosto alto.
Quindi sarebbero degli ottimi coltivatori.
Partendo da questi spunti
è nato un progetto dell'Università di Bologna
che successivamente è diventato
uno spinoff - sempre dell'università -
e si chiama Eugea,
Ecologia Urbana, Giardini e Ambiente
Quello che proponiamo --
cerchiamo di proporre a questi potenziali coltivatori,
cioè a voi,
dei microspot di biodiversità,
dei piccoli angoli da coltivare
magari di fianco alle vostre bellissime piante ornamentali.
Piante però che hanno un senso ecologico.
Quindi, c'è lo spot per le farfalle,
c'è lo spot per gli insetti utili,
c'è la versione tascabile.
Ce ne sono tanti.
Vorremmo coinvolgere tante persone
in modo da creare una rete di biodiversità in città.
Il progetto è nato nel 2007
e ha avuto anche un discreto successo.
Fortunatamente è aumentata la gamma
di quelle che noi chiamiamo
le soluzioni per la biodiversità in città.
Questa è una di queste:
cerchiamo di abbinare natura e poesia.
Scriviamo anche libri.
Siamo anche casa editrice.
Scriviamo dei libri
dove abbiniamo poesie alle piante
Per esempio in questo caso
nel libro dedicato a Emily Dickinson
uno legge le poesie
e poi può ricreare la stessa ambientazione
descritta dalla poetessa americana,
con le stesse piante
perché in allegato
ci sono le piante descritte dalla poetessa
però piante che ricreano anche
lo spot di biodiversità.
Insomma quello che vorremmo fare
è coinvolgere tante persone,
creare una rete molto vasta in città
in modo tale che magari un lunedì mattina
ci potremmo svegliare
e andando al lavoro
così volteggiare nel cielo,
potremmo vedere
questa bellissima farfalla:
il macaone.
È la più bella farfalla italiana.
Purtroppo sta scomparendo.
Se veramente potessimo unirci
e ognuno di noi si prendesse carico
un microspot di biodiversità
questo sogno che --
come diceva Montale
"giace all'ombra della ragione"
potrebbe diventare,
passare da sogno a realtà.
Grazie.
(Applausi)